then you then you think to yourself
right
listen like what's real right and then
you go back to that movie the social
dilemma did you see it
the social dilemma yeah is it with uh
jason bateman
is what jason no no not jason uh
i'm not thinking of robert kane you know
what i'm talking about
no i don't know what you're talking
about social dilemma yeah
i think you're thinking about the social
network
no no i'm trying to think over the movie
that i'm thinking yeah
well i didn't see it oh i'm gonna tell
you okay
that it's a netflix documentary okay
and it's it's all you know how the other
day all the celebrities like we're not
gonna be on instagram and twitter
until you know i mean facebook changes
there you know
but basically it's how social um
media right it's done some good for our
our
our country and our world very little
though people say that a lot and it's
like
people have connected that have never
that haven't talked to each other in
years
right it's like organ donors have been
found it's like dude if you go outside
with a decent organ bruh
somebody will find you dog yeah what i'm
saying but mostly it's
it's it's it's caused polarization in
this country and
a lot of a lot of hate a lot of hate
it's yeah and it's so you know
people say it's trump it's trump it's
like it has a lot to do with you know
you know social media but um so you
watch that and you go
holy [ __ ] i'm never going to be on
twitter but i can't stop
on twitter well yeah because all these
guys celebrities are like
we they saw the document they're like
we're no longer gonna be on twitter
instagram facebook or we're gonna
protest though what do you mean they're
ridiculous they're they just
they say whatever the next thing they
gotta do whatever it's always the next
what do i have to do today to feel like
yeah it's not even there's just no
uniqueness in anymore
you know yeah you know i have a problem
with people when they go
um because sometimes i'll read a comment
and go bobby's hollywood or he's a
celebrity do you
when people call you a celebrity i'd be
real
you don't feel like one right no i don't
feel like one yeah i don't either
like i i feel like when people get
troubled i feel a lot of times
sad yeah i feel like
like i maybe want to become one you know
but i haven't
i haven't gotten there yet but what are
you going to be you're bobby lee man
you're not going to be somebody else
you kind of want to be bruce lee or
something something like guy like that
no dude you're way more bruce lee fought
you're like not a fighter you're true
but i could fight
what is this surge material yeah cuties
it's a show about 13 year old kids like
showing their
you know booties did they cancel it i
don't know no just uh
a lot of people are canceling their
netflix subscriptions to protest
oh my god i think people are so crazy
yeah but it's also it's
it there does you know what with all
technology going back to what you're
saying
there's a spot where you're like okay
does this stuff have
any of my best interests in it like even
if you watch the um
i saw this documentary last night for
about 20 minutes it's about
uh the people
it's basically like five jewish guys
that made tick-tock
and facebook like button
um it's like programmers or something
right yeah and
and just about the dilemma that they're
all facing in dealing with
is this ethical or not yeah dude i just
before i was telling you
about that documentary so the social
dilemma that's what you saw
oh social dilemma yeah my bad so you
[ __ ] saw it
i saw 20 minutes of it dude i didn't
want you to say that
let me explain to you what the [ __ ] it
is and then you're like and then you
were like before
say it man or have nick bring up a
picture what do you think nick's here
for
yeah but you didn't know what it was
called yeah no i didn't and i did
bring up oh my bad you so you did know
oh i'll tell you this bro oh yeah yeah
last time i come to this [ __ ]
birthday party
even good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah